[Music]
tonight on Brian Ross investigates the
family-owned company that makes
oxycontin under fire their strategy was
simple the more drugs they sold the more
money they made and the more people died
now protest against the museums that
have taken money from the Sackler family
we're here to call out the Sacco family
who's become synonymous with the opioid
crisis we're here to call out out all
the museum's to allow the Sackler name
to line their halls tarnish their way
a-dyin at the Guggenheim in New York
led by famed photographer nan goldin who
says oxycontin almost killed her it
almost killed you oh my god
I was on massive doses and my whole life
was oxycontin plus our shout out the
reporter in Alabama who exposed an
arcane law that allowed a county sheriff
to cut back on food for his Jail
prisoners and keep the money for himself
and it's in the day if you make a profit
it's yours he's probably the only person
who watched Shawshank Redemption and was
inspired by the water that's who he
seems like from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City this is
Brian Ross investigates good evening and
welcome tonight a close look at how the
war on drugs is now also becoming a war
on drug manufacturers especially the
company that has made billions of
dollars with oxycontin the highly
addictive painkiller being blamed for
tens of thousands of overdose deaths the
Attorney General of Massachusetts is not
pursuing a full investigation of that
company and the family which owns it the
settlers plaintiff lawyers are lining up
to take the settlers and their company
Purdue Pharma to court and now a new
front an activist group going after the
Sacre's themselves and all the money
they have given to some of the world's
best-known museums Saturday night at the
Guggenheim Museum in New York City
tourists and art lovers taking advantage
of the free admission hours when
suddenly a blizzard of white leaflets
and banners denouncing the sackers
[Applause]
the protests all led by a group called
pain prescription addiction intervention
now a group founded by famed
photographer nan goldin who joined the
so called dyin on the floor of the
Guggenheim all part of an effort to
demand this museum and others like it
around the world give back the millions
of dollars the settlers have donated to
them
[Applause]
refuse money from that it's good it's
very sexy and beautiful and really well
coordinated the Guggenheim didn't know
what was coming
nobody busted us nobody spoke we don't
even use emails
[Music]
the very guerrilla action well that's
the word
[Applause]
oxycontin almost killed me golden told
me that her efforts against the sackers
are all very personal that she herself
was addicted to oxycontin for some three
years the drug first prescribed for her
she says after our wrist injury suffered
in Germany for years the Sackler family
has been one of the great patrons of the
Arts around the world even before their
company began making oxycontin there's a
Sackler wing at the Louvre in Paris at
the Victoria and Albert Museum in London
there's the secular courtyard and the
Sackler centre a sackler Gallery in
Washington a Sackler Museum at Harvard
in New York the Metropolitan Museum of
Art's temple of dendera is housed in the
Sackler wing and down the street at the
Guggenheim
there's the Sackler Center for Arts
education is it fair to ask the museum
to give back the money is one thing but
they can take down the name
they can justify all themselves they can
make a point that they're going to
refuse future funding not just do it
silently but speak out the protest came
as the investigation of the settlers and
their company Purdue Pharma appears to
be picking up speed
we found that Purdue misled doctors
patients and the public about the real
risks of their dangerous opioids
including oxycontin the Attorney General
of Massachusetts Maura Healey released
her own blizzard of documents the result
of a lawsuit she brought last year
against both the company and eight
members of the Sackler family who served
on the Purdue Pharma board their
strategy was simple the more drugs they
sold the more money they made and the
more people died
we found that Purdue engaged in a
multi-billion dollar enterprise to
mislead us about their drugs Purdue
pushed prescribers to give higher doses
to keep patients on drugs for longer
periods of time without regard to the
very real increased risk of addiction
overdose and death in a court filing the
Attorney General revealed the speech
that Richard Sackler then senior vice
president for sales gave at the launch
of oxycontin the launch of oxycontin
tablets will be followed by a blizzard
of prescriptions that will bury the
competition he said the prescription
blizzard will be so deep dense and white
that Gulden's group says it wanted to
create its own blizzard of white
leaflets in the protest at the
Guggenheim documents released by the
Attorney General what does that tell you
attempting murder it tells me that it's
not just money
I mean it's money to a point in Sodor
the Attorney General also made public an
internal email written by Richard
Sackler when he was president of Purdue
Pharma urging company officials to shift
the blame to the people addicted to
oxycontin we have to hammer on the
abusers in every way possible
they are the culprits and the problem
they are reckless criminals Nan Goldin
says her group is emboldened by the
documents being revealed by the
Massachusetts Attorney General it's been
almost a year now since they began their
protests and so far no museum has heated
their call to return the Sackler money
the biggest target being the
Metropolitan Museum of Art in New York
where the group returned once again this
week we're here to call out the Sacco
family who've become synonymous with the
opioid crisis we're here to call out out
all the museum's to allow the Sackler
name to line their halls tarnish their
wings who honored the family who made
billions off the bodies of hundreds of
thousands we came here a year ago we're
knocking on their door they've done
nothing my son Jeffrey was prescribed
oxycontin for a knee surgery in high
school he wanted to wrestle that season
and the doctors told them you can do it
if you take the pills every four hours
take them before the pain starts take
them on schedule they caused me
believing what the doctor said to be an
accomplice to my son's death
when my son talked to his pain I said
did you
take your pill I became an accomplice to
my son's demise that's not right the
Metropolitan Museum of Art says the
sackers have been generous patrons for
almost 50 years that that the museum is
currently engaged in a review of its
gifting policies a spokesperson for the
Sackler family declined to comment on
Mangold the protest or the allegations
she made against the family the company
itself Purdue Pharma says the Attorney
General's complaint is riddled with what
they call demonstrable inaccurate
allegations as for the Guggenheim Museum
our request for someone to appear on our
program tonight was also declined we are
now joined by Barry Meyer who has a
reporter for the New York Times has done
much of the groundbreaking work on
oxycotin and the role of Purdue Pharma
and the sacrifi
he is the author of the book painkillers
an empire of deceit and the origins of
America's opioid epidemic also joining
us by Scott is Rob reach a professor of
political science at Stanford University
and director of the university's McCoy
Center for Ethics in society mr. rishe
is also the author of Just Giving why
philanthropy is failing democracy and
how it can do better
professor Reiss let me start with you
and ask you what do you make of Nan
Goldin protest against the major museums
that carry the Sackler name it's a
fantastic activist effort to get more
people to pay attention to the
long-standing and hardly novel activity
of people who make a lot of money and
then seek to enhance or sometimes
cleanse their reputations by giving
generously as philanthropists and I
think it's appropriate for nan goldin
and all activists to force the
Guggenheim Museum and any other place
that's taken money from the Sackler z--
to make a public statement about why the
museum or the nonprofit entity wishes to
be an accomplice or to be complicit in
the reputation laundering of the Sackler
family you'd call them an accomplice for
taking the money and putting up the
certainly they're complicit in the kind
of public spirited generosity that the
Sackler wished to be known for else they
might not have wanted their name to be
put on the side of all of the buildings
and on the various halls that are the
recipients of their philanthropic gifts
now of course the settlers themselves
have not been charged with the crime the
company did plead guilty to a felony
count of misbranding that the
individuals of the Sackler family were
not charged is it fair to label them in
this way
no well there I'd say it's too early to
say but if they are convicted of crimes
then I think the situation for the
museum's changes dramatically because
we've gone from the act of complicity in
reputation cleansing or laundering to a
new situation in which effectively then
the money received from the Sackler z'
is akin in my mind to something like
stolen goods and I mean here's an easy
way to think about this that if if I
take your watch Brian and I go down to
the pawn shop and sell it and then I
have a bunch of money from your watch
and I give it away to a super effective
nonprofit organization like the
Guggenheim Museum and I tell you look at
all the good that I've done but the
money that I got from your watch you're
just complained to me is I don't care
about the good that you're doing
give me my watch back and repair the
harm that you caused and one thing that
the Guggenheim Museum might consider
doing if the Sackler zarkan dicted of
actual crimes is not merely taking the
Sackler shame off the building not
merely giving the money back to the
Sackler family but giving the money to
the victims of the people who have died
from oxycontin scandal Barry Maher let
me ask you what's the status of the
investigation
does the attorney Journal of the
Massachusetts have the goods you know
it's partly a little too early to tell
Brian these are lawsuits for just
starting to see these documents emerge
but what's startling in this long story
I mean a story that's been going on for
almost 20 years is we really are getting
one of our first glimpses inside
you Perdue for many years has kind of
created the narrative that the Sackler
family was sort of these beneficent
owners of Purdue they sort of were
hands-off but now we're seeing that they
were hands deep in the micromanagement
of the company
these internal emails with Richard
Sackler especially I really do tell the
story that you've been telling for years
there it's stunning I mean you know I
first ran across the Sackler as 20 years
ago and learned about Richard Sackler
and and heard about his activities but
the callousness if that's in fact the
what he was expressing or the view that
only you know bad people would get
addicted to this drug is is sort of
ridiculous because sadly there are
patients people that were customers of
Purdue Pharma who became dependent
and/or addicted to these drugs and with
the Purdue Pharma company now say and
the Attorney General's complaint is
false are trying to vilify unfairly the
company and its executives and they
point out that of all the opioids sold
only 2% are oxycontin and that most of
the deaths now come from aerelon and
fentanyl well let me just say as a
general rule when it comes to Purdue
Pharma they've had a history of blowing
smoke up until the time that they were
criminally convicted of lying to doctors
lying to patients they claimed they were
innocent as snow they claimed that they
were abiding by the laws I would take
anything they say with a grain of salt
and they have also always from the very
beginning tried to minimize their role
in this crisis the fact of the matter is
as Richard Sackler so amply pointed out
they wanted to take over the market for
narcotic painkillers in the United
States that was their goal that was
because they wanted to profit from this
market they wanted to blow away the
competition they did it and there was
huge havoc as a result and the death
toll now some say as many as 400,000
well I mean that's the overall death
toll it's hard to know
how many of those you can assign to
oxycontin and I think it goes beyond the
actual death toll I mean we've become
very fixated on death and overdoses but
there are you know thousands of patients
in this country probably tens of
thousands of people whose lives have not
been changed for the better
from using oxycontin they've been
changed for the worse because they've
become physically emotionally and
psychologically dependent on this drug
they've lost you know their ability to
live daily and they would be far better
off if they were given other types of
pain treatments professor Reese let me
ask you given all of that and the museum
certainly have to know that why have
they not heeded the calls to take the
names out well there's a tension that
any leadership of a nonprofit
organization has all nonprofits need to
raise money to carry out the missions
all the nonprofit leaders are invested
of course in thinking that the mission
that they're pursuing is a good one and
if they can raise money from people that
haven't been convicted of crimes and
that they can extend some social
recognition - well that's common
practice in any large nonprofit
organization now with all these
questions raised but the Sackler family
I think the leadership of the various
museums and cultural institutions need
to say something about why in the light
of these allegations they're willing to
nevertheless accept the money and I mean
to be fair to people who work in
nonprofits of Stanford University where
I'm sitting is one such example one
occasional attitude is that the problem
with tainted money is that there just
ain't enough of it and what excuses the
pursuit of the nonprofit's acceptance of
the money is the goodness of the mission
of the nonprofit and that you can
somehow separate out the means of making
the money and then the good that's done
once the philanthropic gift has been
made and as I said before I think when
actual crime has taken place that
separation is no longer tenable if I do
really good thing
with stolen goods that has nothing at
all to do with the badness of my initial
theft in the case where a theft hasn't
yet been shown or a crime hasn't yet
been shown as with the Sackler these are
just accusations or allegations as I
understand them then I think the
appropriate thing to say to the
leadership of the museum's is that in
light of the allegations what will
happen if they are convicted but will
the museums do and secondly given that
the name still adorn the buildings are
there any lines that a museum would draw
in accepting money from people who are
tarnished in the public eye
professor rish thank you very much very
much thank you very much for being with
us again we asked both the Sackler
family and its company Purdue Pharma
that have someone on our program tonight
but they both declined to do so coming
up our shout out for the reporter who
broke the story about how an Alabama
sheriff kept millions of dollars in
government money that was supposed to
buy food for the jail's inmates and he
says it was all legal when we come back
our shout out tonight to an
investigative reporter in Alabama who
discovered a County Sheriff
who was personally keeping all the
government money he did not spend on
food for prisoners apparently well over
two million dollars into his pocket and
it all started with the tip from the
teenager who moved the sheriff's lawn
and then some deep digging into publicly
available documents sheriff Todd and
ricchan quickly denounced the stories as
faked news a political smear over the
past two weeks me my family my office
the citizens Vetter wall county have
been targets of miscellaneous fake news
stories but reporter Connor sheets of
al.com says he was confident he got it
right standing behind his stories and a
video describing nightmare conditions at
the Gadsden Alabama jail and detailing
how some of the money for food ended up
in the sheriff's personal bank account
but we know that he kept over 2.5
million dollars become but we only
really have snippets based on which
documents I was able to obtain the story
was picked up across the state and
around the country and Alabama sheriff
was defiant today as he defended his
practice of pocketing leftover money
from the inmates food budgets he's taken
in well more than $250,000 a year the
most he's required to report
rich material for the link he's probably
the only person who watched Shawshank
Redemption and was inspired by the
warden that's what he seems like sheet
says former prisoners in jail employees
told him the sheriff was cutting food
costs with food that was donated rotten
or worse a meat product that would come
in it was kind of gray and drab and some
of them want something called its
starfish patties they said it looked
like a starfish once it was chopped up
but essentially it was wrapped in a
in a plastic wrapping sort of like a you
know like a roll sausage and then not
wrapping and the box that it came in
both said in red bold letters not fit
for human consumption the sheriff said
prisoners should not expect anything
more than three square meals a day now
let me be clear this is a jail this is
not a bed and breakfast dominoes does
not deliver here we don't run to
McDonald's and get these prisoners or
Chinese Big Macs wow I don't know if
this guy knows how to run a prison but
he knows his fuss food restaurant say
yeah you as he was describing his meal
plan for himself that's what it sounded
like we're not gonna get you the crispy
bacon later with the cheese and we're
not gonna get you the mac Florrie with
Oreo swirl or the Arby's meat Mountain
now that one's off menu so you gotta ask
for it we're not gonna Darrell
but the biggest reveal came when she's
reported it was all legal under an
arcane state law that makes the sheriff
personally responsible for feeding his
prisoners it's the law I'm not having
done anything wrong and it's the end of
the day if you make a profit it's yours
she's reporting found that may be true
with state money but not necessarily
with the money the federal government
pays to house immigration detainees at
the state level the governor has already
changed the policy for the state the
state legislators are looking now to
push me laws and there's been
investigations launched at the federal
local and state levels so I think
whether or not it's legal at this time
is to some degree didn't beside the
point I feel like that just gives public
officials an incentive to do their jobs
badly like I don't think it would be a
good idea so that firefighters keep any
money they save on water you know for
all the jokes Conor sheets investigation
was a serious look at an often
underreported condition involving local
Jews
sheet says he is far from true with his
investigation which last week was named
one of the finalists for the prestigious
Goldsmith award at Harvard University so
a shout out for Connor sheets and his
bosses at Alabama Media Group and their
newspapers in Birmingham Huntsville and
mobile sometimes the real scandal is not
what's illegal but what's legal that's
our program for night thanks for joining
us we'll see you back here next week